[Music]
and now a love perv from the bible
your hair is like a flock of goats your
teeth are like a flock of shawn use
your neck is like the tower of david
wait no stop
what is this thing how is this meant to
be romantic
where hindu traditions have the kama
sutra the bible has its own attempt at
erotic literature introducing the song
of songs this version is graphic in an
entirely different way why use such an
unusual description are we meant to take
it literally welcome to the world of
ancient eastern love poetry where
cherubs don't look like this but instead
look like this
let's begin
the song of songs is from the old
testament it's a bit of an odd one out
in the bible to be honest there's no
storyline no clear reference to god and
certainly no fire and brimstone as you'd
expect instead it's one elegant love
poem where a young couple expresses
their desire for one another the name
itself the song of songs is a hebrew
idiom that basically means the greatest
song of all time the goat song if you
will as will become apparent a bit later
on predominantly said in a lush garden a
man and a woman trade romantic
descriptions of one another it
culminates in a grand proclamation that
love is as strong as death it's arguably
the finest example of ancient hebrew
poetry we have full of word plays and
rhythms that are often lost when
translated now since we're dealing with
poetry all those words from high school
english class are back similes assonance
onomatopair the key one to remember here
is metaphor the idea of using figurative
speech to describe something when it
comes to the song of songs you might
argue that it gets a little bit carried
away so without further ado let me read
you one of the descriptions the man
gives to his beloved
how beautiful you are my love how very
beautiful
your eyes are doves
your hair is like a flock of goats
moving down the slopes of gilead your
teeth are like a flock of sean use and
not one among them is bereaved your lips
are like a crimson thread your cheeks
are like halves of a pomegranate your
neck is like the tower of david on it
hang a thousand bucklers all of them
shields of warriors your two breasts are
like two thorns twins of a gazelle that
feed among the lilies your lips distill
nectar my bride honey and milk are under
your tongue
the scent of your garments is like the
scent of lebanon i can think of a whole
bunch of words to describe how i'm
feeling but romantic is not one of them
now full disclaimer this unsettling
description is not meant to be taken
literally no instead all the language is
metaphorical some are relatively simple
to figure out from a distance goats on a
hill sort of look like long flowing hair
if you squint
a lot and teeth like a flock of sean use
without a bereavement possibly means a
full white set of sparkly teeth no gaps
here however we can't figure out what
some of the other more elaborate
descriptions might mean like for example
the one about her neck being like the
tower of david was there a building
called david's tower was it long and
slender or strong and regal and what on
earth could those shields hanging from
it mean these references might have been
known to audiences back then but today
they're completely lost on us after all
it's been some 2500 years it's true the
imagery is hard to grasp but poetry has
always loved being cryptic even one of
the greatest love perks william
shakespeare used all sorts of vague
imagery in his works some of them in
fact might have been lifted from the
song of songs take this extract from the
climax of romeo and juliet death that
hath sucked the honey of thy breath hath
had no power yet upon thy beauty thou
art not conquered beauty's ensign yet is
crimson in thy lips and in thy cheeks
honey breath crimson lips and cheeks
sound familiar what's more the idea that
death is unable to conquer love is just
like how in the song of songs it
declares that love is as strong as death
who'da thought perhaps it takes a great
poet to appreciate great poetry
shakespeare also wrote that love is
blind but to be honest i'm not sure
that's always the case you see taking
care of yourself is a must and that's
why this video is sponsored by manscaped
like it or not the season of love is
upon us whatever your valentine's day
looks like feeding your best starts with
looking your best that's why the good
folks at manscaped are here to help you
with all your shaving and body hair
needs introducing the performance
package 4.0 your all-in-one head-to-toe
men's grooming and hygiene kit this
nifty trimmer is called the lawnmower
4.0 and has been specifically designed
with advanced skin safe technology to
help reduce any nicks and cuts on the
most sensitive areas of your body it
also comes with these two very handy
products you can use after your shave
the crop preserver which makes sure that
everything is smelling good and a crop
reviver which makes sure everything is
feeling good the kit also includes their
weed whacker nose and ear hair trimmer
you think that would be enough but no
for a limited time when you get the
performance package 4.0 kit you get not
one but two free gifts this neat travel
bag and a pair of anti-chafing boxer
briefs for a special bonus for the
viewers of this channel when you head to
manscape.com and use the promo code
hochalaga at checkout you get 20 off
plus free international shipping plus
those two free gifts from earlier not
bad
link down in the description below to
get started thank you manscaped okay
back to the video being one long love
poem the song of songs is a pretty
unusual biblical book something which
has bothered scholars about it is that
there are no overt religious
connotations to it either it's simply a
celebration between two lovers so what
on earth is it doing in the bible what
might have happened is that religious
traditions saw it as an allegory you
know it says one thing but means another
early jews saw it as a love story
between god and israel centuries later
christians added jesus into the mix for
example early christian thinker origin
trying to explain how christ is the man
and the church is his bride in biblical
scholarship today there has been a move
away from these interpretations instead
of trying to bury the sexual overtones
scholars have embraced the eroticism and
viewed it more in its historical context
in fact plenty neighboring civilizations
had their own love poetry some of the
best examples have come out of ancient
egypt in the mid-20th century
archaeologists were digging in dare el
medina and on earth a bunch of love
songs inscribed on papyri they date to
1300 bce making them over 3000 years old
when i'm reading it think back to the
song of songs
she has no rival
there is no one like her she is the
fairest of all such beautiful eyes when
she stares and sweet lips when she
speaks with a long neck and shining body
her hair of genuine lapis lazuli her arm
more brilliant than gold her fingers
like lotus flowers ample behind tight
waist her thighs extend her beauty
shapely in stride when she steps on the
earth
how nice is that far easier to grasp
than the hebrew one for sure but it's
not just ancient egypt they even had
romantic literature in mesopotamia as
well this clay tablet is believed to
contain the oldest love perm of all time
it's called the love song of shusin it's
an ancient sumerian hymn believed to
date to 2000 bce that's 4 000 years ago
it describes a sacred marriage between
the human king shu sin and the goddess
in nana and was likely used in fertility
rituals here it is
bridegroom dear to my heart goodly is
your beauty honey sweet lion did in my
heart goodly is your beauty honey sweet
bridegroom let me caress you my precious
caress is more savoury than honey in the
bed chamber honey filled let me enjoy
your goodly beauty another charming perm
out of the ancient world seems like the
sumerians had a soft side to them after
all and notice all the references to
honey similar to the language used in
the song of songs by the way have you
ever wondered what the oldest song of
all time sounds like consider watching
my video on the who in him to learn more
about the earliest known piece of
written music
exploring the love poetry of the ancient
world reveals that the song of songs was
just one love perm amongst many and it
wasn't the only text to use elaborate
symbolic imagery to me this biblical
hymn which cherishes and celebrates the
love between two people brings so much
humanity into the ancient world it
reminds us that these ancient people
were just like us they laughed the way
we laugh cried the way we cry and loved
the way we love when it comes to bizarre
romantic metaphors however
well not quite so much nope that's still
strange to the modern day
wonderful
but strange
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one and thank you
manscape for sponsoring this video
if you liked this video why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way oh and whilst you're
here be sure to check out some of my
other stuff especially my video on the
oldest known song of all time
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye